♪
BRIAN: ONE OF THE BIGGEST
STORIES OF THE WEEK THE OWNER OF
MAC’S PUBLIC HOUSE IN STATEN
ISLAND, NEW YORK SAID HE WOULD
RATHER GO TO JAIL THAN CLOSE HIS
DOORS IT WOULD BE FOR GOOD IS
STILL REFUSING TO BACK DOWN.
HIS STORY INSPIRED HUNDREDS,
THOUSANDS I WOULD SAY TO SHOW UP
AND PROTEST FOR HIM ABOUT THE
CITY’S LOCKDOWN THAT’S COMING
OUR WAY.
SENDING THE MESSAGE THEY STAND
WITH HIM AND ALL THESE OTHERS
FIGHTING TO SAVE LIVELIHOODS.
DANIEL PRESSIE JOINS US NOW.
MAC’S IS STILL CLOSED.
HOW ARE YOU GOING TO GET IT
OPEN?
WHAT IS THE GAME PLAN FOR HERE?
>> THE NEXT COUPLE DAYS MAC’S
WILL BE OPEN.
WE ARE WORKING ON THAT AND RIGHT
NOW SITTING DOWN WITH OUR LEGAL
TEAM AND TRYING TO AT THIS POINT
WORK WITH THE CITY PLEADED WITH
THEM TO WORK WITH US AND OTHER
SMALL BUSINESSES.
AS I SAID IN THE BEGINNING WE
ARE LOSING FAITH AND LOST FATE
FOR THE CITY AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS TO HELP US.
THE IMMEDIATE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS
ARE HELPING US.
THOSE OFFICIALS.
THE GOVERNOR AND THE MAYOR SEEM
LIKE THEY DON’T WANT ANYTHING.
AT SYSTEM POINT IF THEY DON’T
GIVE US ASSISTANCE IN SOME WAY
OR ARE WORKING WITH US TO GET
THINGS BACK OPEN, AGAIN, IN A
SAFE MANNER WE WILL HAVE TO TAKE
THINGS IN OUR OWN HANDS.
WE HAVE BEEN IN CONTACT WITH IAN
SMITH FROM ATILIS GYM IN BELL
MARCH, NEW JERSEY.
TOGETHER WE ARE CREATED A UNITED
FRONT.
WE ARE SETTING UP THE
INFRASTRUCTURE.
AND WHAT WE ARE TRYING TO DO IS
GET RESOURCES FOR ALL BUSINESSES
THAT WANT TO STAY OPEN TO REMAIN
OPEN.
AND WE ARE GOING TO GIVE THEM
ALL THE INFORMATION AND EVEN
OTHER PEOPLE, NOT INCLUDING
SMALL BUSINESSES, JUST PEOPLE
THAT WANT TO SHOW SUPPORT AND
HELP THE INFORMATION WILL BE
AVAILABLE FOR THEM AS WELL.
BRIAN: HERE IS WHAT GOVERNOR
CUOMO SAID.
THIS OWNER IS LEARNING THAT
ACTIONS HAVE CONSEQUENCES TO PUT
LIVES AT RISK IN A PANDEMIC IS
UNACCEPTABLE.
BRIAN: WHAT IS HE TALKING ABOUT
POLITICAL STATEMENT?
ALL HE WANTS TO DO IS EARN A
LIVING.
WHAT POLITICAL STATEMENT ARE YOU
MAKING?
>> THAT’S EXACTLY IT.
WE WOULD LIKE TO TAKE POLITICS
OUT OF IT.
BUT THEY SEEM TO CREEP INTO
EVERYTHING, NO MATTER WHAT.
WE JUST NEED IN SOME WAY TO
EITHER BE ASSISTED OR TO GET OUR
PLACES OPEN.
AND THESE STATE AGENCIES, AND
CITY AGENCIES THAT COME IN AND
THREATEN TO FINE US OR PULL OUR
LICENSES EVERY SINGLE DAY, IT’S
NOT RIGHT.
AND THESE AGENCIES SHOULD BE
COMING IN ASSISTING US AND
SAYING HOW CAN WE HELP YOU AND
WHAT SUPPORT DO YOU NEED AND IF
YOU NEED ANY INFORMATION, WE ARE
HERE TO HELP YOU.
INSTEAD, WE HAVE THESE -- THE
STATE LIQUOR AUTHORITY AND CSE
AND ALL THESE AGENCIES KICKING
OPEN THE DOOR AND THEN
THREATENING TENS OF THOUSANDS OF
DOLLARS OF FINES EVERY DAY AND
I’M GETTING CALLS FROM ALL THESE
SMALL BUSINESS OWNERS SAYING
WHAT WE CAN WE DO?
THIS IS WHAT WE SAYING TO OUR
GOVERNMENTS AND GOVERNOR CUOMO
AND THE MAYOR YOU HAVE TO STOP
THIS AND ASSIST US.
BRIAN: HE IS NOT DANNY, YOU ARE
FORGETTING, THIS GOVERNOR IS AN
EGO MANIAC.
IS HE AN EMMY AWARD WINNER.
HE LOVES CELEBRITIES.
HE LOVES HIMSELF.
HE LOVES TO HEAR HIMSELF TALK
AND HE HAS NO INTEREST IN YOUR
BUSINESS.
SADLY.
BUT WE DO.
AND I HOPE YOU KEEP FIGHTING.
BECAUSE YOU ARE DOING THINGS
RESPONSIBLY.
THEY’RE LETTING BARS OPEN A FEW
BLOCKS AWAY FROM YOU BUT THEY
SHUT YOU DOWN BECAUSE OF A ZIP
CODES.
AS IF THE VIRUS KNOW AS ZIP